hello everyone
i'm sad omer i'm the director of the
yale institute for global health
also known as ygh and welcome to the ygh
global health conversation series this
is a venue to learn from
and connect with innovative leaders in
global health
um in addition to ygh we indebted to the
george herbert walker junior lecture
at the macmillan center at gale for
course sponsoring today's event
uh while we have seen progress uh and
significant challenges remain in our
global health response to covert 19.
the the pandemic continues to take a
devastating toll
in communities around the world in
critically
important issues are especially around
equity
and the availability of vaccines remain
so if we were to
beat back covet 19 we need to respond as
a global community
the world health organization as most of
you know plays a central role if not the
central role
in marshalling the global response to
the covet 19 pandemic
and many other critical health issues
over the next hour we will discuss a
range of issues
uh including the importance of ensuring
equity
in tackling the pandemic the value and
role of
of the wh so in the world and
since we are connecting
from the us at our side the importance
of re-engaging
the united states in the global response
it is truly an honor for me to introduce
today's
guest dr ted ross adonam
uh gabrielesis um he was elected
the director general of who in may 2017
and is the first person from the who
african region
to head the world's leading public
health agency
he has been a pioneer in global health
well before his start with who as the
director general
he was born in the eritrean city of
asmara dr treadwest graduated from the
university
of asmara with the bachelor of biology
before earning a master of science in
immunology of infectious diseases
uh from the university of london a phd
in community health from the university
of nottingham and an
honorary fellowship from the london
school of hygiene and tropical medicine
following his studies uh dr tedros
returned to ethiopia
to support the delivery of health
services and doing some
pioneering work um starting as a field
level
malariologist before heading a regional
health service
and later serving in ethiopia's federal
government for over a decade
as minister of health and minister of
foreign affairs
under his leadership ethiopia expanded
its health infrastructure
developed innovative health financing
mechanisms
and expanded its health workforce
a particular a major component of
reforms he drove
was the creation of a primary health
care
extension program that deployed
approximately 40 000 female health
workers throughout the country
a significant result was an approximate
60
reduction in child and maternal
mortality compared to the 2000
level um so as minister of
uh foreign affairs from 2012 to 2016 he
elevated
health as a profession uh
helped as a political issue nationally
regionally
as well as globally and in this role he
led efforts to negotiate
the sababa action agenda in which uh
193 countries committed to the finance
uh financing necessary to achieve
sustainable development goals
prior to his election as the dg for who
dr tedros held many leadership positions
in global health
including the chair of the global health
fund for
a fund to fight aids uh tuberculosis and
malaria
chair of the rollback malaria
partnership
and co-chair of the partnership for
maternal newborn and childhood board
after taking office as uh the who
director general
in 2017 he initiated the most
significant
organizational transformation uh in that
organization's history
which has generated a wide range of
achievements
welcome dr tedros we're so pleased to
have you here with us today
and would love to start with a few
remarks from you
thank you thank you so much saad can you
hear me
absolutely lord loud and clear thank you
thank you my friend
um first of all i would like to say i
just
started earlier telling you um
i have a very strong link with yale
university
that started when i was minister of
health in ethiopia
and the bridge was your own
director of global health at the time
now she is the president of vassar
college
dr elizabeth bradley i call her betsy
so we had a partnership yale university
clinton foundation and ethiopian
ministry of health
on hospital reform uh but
it didn't just stop there uh we
cooperated on hospital reform and we had
one of the biggest
uh reforms in ethiopia together the
three of us ministry of health
of ethiopia yale university and um
clinton foundation and that was followed
actually when i became foreign minister
we continued the partnership and we used
to have
trainings organized by yell you know
john lewis goddess on grand strategy
and training our diplomats on grand
strategy
of course we use grand strategy also for
for our reform
in in um ethiopia with the support from
betsy and
john gaddis so i will stop there but i
have many many stories uh
i could have told you link to yell
but i would like to thank betsy who has
been the center
a force of nature actually who
helped in reforming the
health sector in ethiopia
but not only betsy i have many friends
and i would like to say hello
and greetings to to all of you and i
hope this pandemic will be behind us
and i will have a chance to come to
visit you at rtl and of course my
sister betsy in basser i don't know if
she's listening to this
she once yell always yell so
she might be then
greetings also to the members and the
students of the yell institute
for global health and to all the people
following this
event online and thank you for the
opportunity to
to be with you today and to discuss the
critical need for equitable access to
health services worldwide
and the essential steps we must take to
achieve this
first i would like to give a special
thanks to our moderator my friend
saad rumer for his kind words
as well as the support he's providing
who and the world
as a member of the who technical
advisory group we call tag
on behavioral insights which is actually
a new addition
and part of the transformation in in in
double h o
this independent expert group is
advising wh on understanding
the many factors that affect people's
behaviors
and practices which is vital for helping
countries
design more equitable health policies
and programs of course the chair is
professor cass
and they were working with very closely
prohibited cars from
harvard this is the type of work
that's critical to who's efforts to
advance
health for all which includes not only
universal health coverage but also the
social
environmental and economic policies and
factors
that affect health as kobe 19
has harshly illustrated equity
matters this pandemic has thrived
amid the inequalities and inequities in
our societies
and exploited the gaps in our health
systems
it has exacerbated the disparities
between
and within countries but
while the pandemic has affected all of
us the poorest
and most marginalized have been hit
hardest
both in terms of lives and livelihoods
laws
the impact of the covet 19 crisis pushed
an estimated 120 million people into
extreme poverty
last year gender inequalities have
significantly increased
with more women than men leaving the
labor force
and as we speak rich countries are
vaccinating their populations while the
world's poor
watch and wait
as you may know high and upper
middle-income countries
which account for 53 percent of the
world's population
have administered 83 percent of the
world's vaccines
meanwhile low and lower middle-income
countries
which make up 47 percent of the world's
people
have received just 17 percent of the
world's vaccines
the inequitable distribution of vaccines
is a moral outrage
it's also economically and
epidemiologically
self-defeating as covid19 has shown
the pandemic is more than a health
crisis
it has had grave consequences for
livelihoods
businesses and economies
the pandemic has shown that when health
is at risk
everything is at risk but when
health is protected and promoted
individuals
families communities economies
and nations can try
health should not be seen as a cost
but as an investment in productive
resilient and inclusive societies
but globally as you're observing
we're going in the wrong direction
around the world more households are
spending an
increasing proportion of their income on
health
and more people are being exposed to
poverty
as a result of out of pocket health
spending it's clear that making progress
toward this universal health coverage
cannot just be a matter of a matter for
ministries of health
but takes an all-of-government approach
with leadership from the highest
political
levels at the united nations
general assembly in 2019 just a few
months before the pandemic started
u.n member states endorsed the
high-level political declaration
on universal health coverage
we must learn the lessons of this
parliament
and build on the political momentum for
equity to mobilize investments for
healthier
more resilient and more sustainable
societies
in closing i would like to offer a few
things to consider
as you move forward in your studies and
your careers
in global health first
remember that health is part of a larger
ecosystem
that encompasses environmental social
economic and political factors
that's why it's important for health
professionals
and policy makers to take a
multi-sectoral
approach don't be afraid to work across
disciplines partnerships
can make us stronger and achieve the
desired result
second search for examples of what works
in countries
and communities around the world
rivers engineer them and see what might
inspire further research
leading to tangible global change
and best practices can be found
everywhere
in high-income countries low-income
countries middle-income countries
and the pandemic has shown us that even
the countries the high-income countries
were very vulnerable
and third let's rethink
the narrative around health
not as a cost but
as an investment in our common future
stronghold systems and global health
security
are two sides of the same coin
now let's get started with our
discussion
i'm looking forward to your questions
thank you
again uh professor saad romer
and back to you thank you
and and thanks for the kind words about
yale and your previous interaction and
collaboration and work with
with this institution um you know you
since you mentioned
betsy bradley uh she and i had a
um a chat a few weeks ago
around an event and she was very much
planning to attend and she's likely to
be
listening in and and streaming this uh
so
uh rest assured one of your old friends
is um
is very much here uh is likely to be
here like uh
i haven't confirmed it but but she was
intending to attend
so i think you know thanks for laying
out this vision
for an equitable future in health
but focusing on the more short term
um how does how do we as a global
community
work towards equitable access to
vaccines treatments and other health
services
in this pandemic
no thank you thank you very much i think
what's key and
um especially ensuring equitable access
is
um political commitment
and that political commitment should
actually emanate from a belief that
um sharing or cooperation
sharing of vaccines that's cooperation
is in the
interest of every individual country
so any country you name should should
believe that
the vaccine equity is
good to end this pandemic and it's in
the interest of all of us
or in the interest of every nation
i can give you one example for instance
you know new variants are appearing
i know many countries are moving
especially high-income countries are
moving with high vaccination coverage
some of them may achieve 70 or 80
percent
by summer or end of the this year
but if the rest of the world remains
unvaccinated or low coverage like what
we see now 0.3 percent in low-income
countries
then the new variants will continue to
mutate
and then you may find variants that may
actually evade the vaccines that are
already
being used then
those countries who believe that they
have already high coverage
will be affected because there is a new
guy a new virus
mutated significantly means a new one
it's almost like new
that will again affect them
so they're doing it for their own
interests and i think that
understanding will help in vaccine
equity nothing else to be honest
and the second maybe the to see the
other way
this is a common enemy and unless we
fight it together
unless we fight it in unison
it will use it will not be defeated
and if we're divided it will use the
divisions to attack us
so if we're divided we're more
vulnerable
if we work in unison then we will be
able to defeat
this this virus and end the pandemic as
soon as as soon as possible
so it's a must actually the only way to
end this pandemic is through cooperation
so that's it it's really realizing
uh this issue that will i mean realizing
this that will help us
and then of course i understand there
are some concerns for instance
um the private sector i think we need to
put people before profits
and we we have to make a choice
because making profits will be at the
expense of
losing many lives and at the expert then
at the expense of extending
you know the um the uh pandemic
so um i mean it's very clear for those
who want to to
to act and then of course if there is
political commitment then you move
into increasing production
capacity by waiving ip for instance if
you believe that
you know people come first before profit
then you wave
ip and you take other measures like
technology transfer and so on to
increase production
have enough supplies to share
but to make that happen you will need
also money
so you need to mobilize resources as we
speak now we need 19 billionaires
dollars
for accelerator but we're not
getting it of course the
u.s has contributed 4 billion u.s
dollars but still there is a
gap but as you know many high-income
countries are already spending a lot of
money for their stimulus package
19 billion compared to the stimulus
package is a very small
amount of money so if there is real
commitment which i say the political
commitment
then the financing should also should
also come because the
increased production capacity cannot
come without
financing so if we do political
commitment and that means will be
followed by
taking every action to increase
production
and then to increase production we will
need financing if we do those
and if we identify this virus as a
common
enemy and it's in the interest of all of
us
i think the vaccine equity uh can be
can be done thank you back to you
no i think i think thanks for
highlighting the value of
global engagement with who switching to
the us
what does that partnership look like
moving forward and then what
explicitly is needed from your
perspective from the biden
administration
to fulfill the promise of who and the
multilateral system
yeah thank you so much first of all
i would like to start by thanking
the biden administration
as you may remember during the election
campaign
he promised to reverse the
former um administration's decision
the day of his inauguration so he signed
a letter actually
on january 20th that reverses
the decision so he kept his promise
and second um i had a call on 21st
january the day i received the letter
from his excellency the president
i received a call from vice president
kamala harris
and you know on u.s commitment to work
with who
and to help global health
and then third i had a call with
um the same day actually
there was a presentation to our board by
tony fauci
and then of course i had a call after
the secretary of health was
appointed with um um with
secretary xavier bisera
you can see the strong commitment
and i have to really appreciate that
and what i expect is what the
biden administration is saying now
for the u.s to be in who
is good for the us
good for the us and good for the us
citizens
and good for the rest of the world and
good for wgo
so joining who working with double a
choice in the interest of the us
byron administration believes this and
we believe that by the way
and it's in the interest of the rest of
the world
that mentality is important
because it's it's the mindset that leads
you to effective partnership
so the mindset of this administration is
us benefits
the rest of the world benefits if the us
engage established
that's very important and that's why
they're doing what they're doing now and
which we were expecting
joining kovacs supporting kovacs with 4
billion u.s
u.s dollars and also
you know reactivating all the program
support they have been providing
us the financial support and working
with us very closely not only to fight
covet
but to fight other diseases as well
yeah so it's it's um
this is what we have been expecting
and we we see that uh
that's happening and um we will continue
to work
with the us very very closely
um and um you know have better outcome
in the fight against this pandemic but
at the same time in in other
programs too
wonderful uh so um you know more than
two dozen countries and the european
council president have signed
a statement calling for the creation of
an uh of a new international treaty
uh for pandemic preparedness and
response what should be the key elements
of us treaty and
and and your overall perspective on the
treaty and and what should be the who's
role
yeah thank you as you know um
before the pandemic many people
many institutions including who were
saying
the world is unprepared for a pandemic
and what we see now is exactly that
and not only we were saying the world is
unprepared but we were proposing
solutions
or actions um
but i think action was late and that's
why
the pandemic is now wrecking havoc
and we know
we now know
how unprepared we were and we now know
what the major problems were
um more than ever before of course
we knew them but even the hardest way
we know now and the problems are poor
national capacity
in emergency preparation response and at
the same time
poor global capacity
when there is poor poor or weak national
capacity
it makes us vulnerable as an as a globe
and our strength is as strong as
the weakest link or we are globally as
weak as
the weakest link unless we address
the weaknesses that that that we have so
this is very clear now and the
investment should stop from
national building national capacity
and the pandemic treaty can help the
maybe if i go to specific other
challenges problems
that are common factor we be it as
national capacity or global capacities
for instance we have seen weaknesses in
sharing data very serious problem
there are problems in sharing pathogens
or biological material
and there is a problem in sharing
technology like vaccines we just we have
been discussing
and there is a problem in sharing
resources like financing
financing preparedness and response
so we believe that the new
i mean the pandemic treaty which we are
now pushing for
can address these gaps
without sharing information you cannot
fight
an outbreak epidemic or pandemic
that has to be addressed without sharing
the pathogens and if there is a problem
in sharing pathogens
and you know all the problems associated
with that
and without sharing vaccines now you see
the disparity and the virus is
continuing to
wreak havoc throughout the world so we
believe the pandemic treaty can address
this specific weak weaknesses among
other things
of course the pandemic treaty is not all
about these five things i raised
it's more than that but these are some
of the critical ones
so national capacity global capacity
sharing information sharing pathogens or
biological material
sharing technology like vaccines and
sharing
resources and strengthen the whole
global preparedness and response that's
what the pandemic treaty
can do and there is an opportunity now
because of the pandemic
and let's use this pandemic as an
opportunity
like saying there is as the saying goes
use every crisis as an opportunity if
we're going to use this crisis as
opportunity
then the solution pandemic treaty
that addresses the major weaknesses we
had
is very important and something that we
can
pass to our children and grandchildren
so before the pandemic right before the
pandemic and if i can
sort of editorialize a little bit just
right just in time for the pandemic
um you launched an initiative to
transform the secretariat transform
while
so there's been a lot of you know public
discussion as there is in these kinds of
situations about
uh you know how the pandemic will impact
who's trans
transformation so what are your thoughts
on it
and and as one would think that you know
if it ain't broke don't fix it
in terms of certain aspects while other
aspects might
require some change uh what are your
what is your perspective on on that kind
of a discussion
yeah thank you i mean that's a very
important question
um you know i will take you back
actually when i was running for my
campaign
to for this position for dg
one of the priorities for priorities one
of them was
emergency preparedness and response
and then as soon as i was elected
the first major speech i had
was on pandemic preparedness and
response and that was in columbia
university in september 2017.
september 2017 and i was asked to choose
you know um you know whatever
area i would like to speak about and i
i say pandemic preparedness and i
i told actually the audience a story and
how
that started in the us and then
in a military camp in the west
and then um how that traveled to
the east in new york
you know even started community
transmission and
across the atlantic to europe
i didn't tell them what it was but i was
just telling
the story and how many people were
killed and then i told them
the same thing can happen now this
happened in 1918
but the same thing can happen now
then of course we started the design of
the transformation
and because it was my election promise
so
one of the pillars was emergency
and um we started
actually building things that are very
important for emergency preparedness and
and response not only the talk in
colombia the first
major speech i had as a dg as after i
became bg but
that was real our fear was real and
that's why
i made it part of the transformation
and we established as a result of the
transformation
new emergency preparedness division
just for preparedness and then a new
science division
with the first ever chief scientist
was established and of course data we
pulled all data functions together
and we
articulated with clarity some of the
changes we need to
make in order to help with emergency
preparedness but of course the rest of
the
programs uh also who academy
to help us with training because you
need to build
capacity and that's very very important
and of course other things i don't want
to waste your time
and of the time of our our audience
students by
listing all but most of the things we
have done
um as part of our transformation were
very relevant for emergency response
actually we used those to fight
the pandemic although these things were
done just few months before the pandemic
but they were very helpful in many ways
i wish we had more time it was like
immediate
and now um
from what i see it's a matter of
building on what we have started
and the other very important element in
our transformation was
to to make who a learning organization
to make change constant
meaning we will take the recommendations
from the different panels from the ippr
from the ihr review committee from iowa
from other platforms even if you have
crazy ideas from your university which
i'm really close to give us
this pandemic is unprecedented it has
affected everybody
everybody on earth every life so
we need to listen and accommodate that
and continue to change
wha so we have started
why transformation is important um
[Music]
we have started that transformation
journey i mean and we know why
transformation is important but we even
know that
change should be a constant and we
should accommodate
change and recalibrate and reposition wh
of course the whole global capacity on
on regular
basis so there is no problem that we
started we started something
that that's helpful for emergency
preparedness and response
it's a matter of building on it but we
need to accommodate more this is
unprecedented so we should we should do
even more
we should even change things more
significantly than it
is now that's
wonderful and and and thanks for being
open to ideas
uh so that's the you know um
that's that's a that's a great way of
looking at it sort of how as a globe
we learned from this experience and and
just as an aside uh yale is well
represented in some of these things
uh as you know uh uh professor ernesto
zedello
former president of mexico is a yale
professor and
is a part of the ippr so so there is
uh you know that input so switching to
the um the audience questions and we're
getting some
some very interesting questions and and
one question i think you briefly touched
upon that but but you might want to
expand on that because of the
specificity of the question and and and
this
you know questionnaire acknowledges a
questionnaire
acknowledges that uh or highlights the
disjointed nature of the global response
from various countries and and other
entities private or public
is there one specific item that jumps
to mind as the most critical step we as
a global community could take
to minimize such discontinuity
in the future can you rephrase the
question
so so the pro
the premise of the question is that
there has been some discontinuity in the
response
by you know various countries and
private and public entities
is there a single step or a sort of a
finite
set of steps that come to your mind that
would prevent that from happening
in terms of a disjointed response
from happening in future pandemics and
large public health emergencies
so when you say disjointed are you
talking about global or
in in country level i i'm talking about
global between countries
so you mean no uniformity in response
exactly so no uniformity so uh you know
europe's uh uh response not harmonized
with this response and the response and
sort of various countries
implementing strategies that has have
global
implications even for example on supply
chains uh for
vaccines and um and treatment
um non-pharmaceutical interventions and
and so on and so forth
um and so so that fragmentation
perhaps hasn't served us well is there
anything
first of all feel free to question the
the premise of of
of this question uh but but if you do
agree that there has been this
fragmented response this time by various
countries how are there mechanisms that
come to your mind
that could help prevent that yeah thank
you thank you very much
first of all i i don't think it would be
a surprise
to the students but i'll tell you one
thing
those who were not listening are
actually the high-income countries
because they they think that they have
the best system on earth
so they don't listen to double joe
but who has
experts that come from different
countries
so no country can claim that it has
better capacity than double what because
we are a collection of
diverse experiences and capacities
that could be better than any single
country and
advice from who is like a collective
advice from
a center that accommodates all the
experience and practices of many
countries
so i think
that's one meaning the high-income
countries should take who seriously
and when who advises they should they
should listen
you may remember some high-income
countries when we say
this virus is very dangerous
they were saying oh it's flu we can
manage it
when we say this virus is public enemy
number one
in february last year maybe you remember
they were saying no no no we can let it
circulate and then there could be herd
immunity
by letting it circulate freely
and then we will be okay we never
we fought back saying no it's not a flu
it's a very dangerous virus it's it's
very transmittable
it's a killer it has these two dangerous
combinations
that's why we call it public enemy
number one and
sadly the high-income countries were not
taking it seriously because they believe
that
they have better capacity that's very
important by the way
um and then of course
even if you don't categorize by high
middle and low-income countries
many countries because of many other
reasons that they were not
following the advices so
going forward what do we do to
address this problem that's why we're
saying pandemic treaty
there will be areas that will
address you know um
um the
important elements that the countries
should really observe
all countries whether they are high
middle
or low low income countries and
accommodating it in the pandemic treaty
would be very
very important but even in the absence
of the pandemic treaty now
uniformity of action or response is very
important
because when there is uniformity
and when all countries do the same thing
at the same time
the virus will not get a space to
maneuver
and very simple and anybody can
understand it
you deny the virus a space to maneuver
when you act as one that's why we have
been calling for cooperation
that's why we have been asking for
solidarity
we have been proposing actions publicly
and we have been saying please do it all
because we we knew that the same action
everywhere could actually stop or slow
uh the virus so going forward i think
institutionalizing
the solutions will be important and the
pandemic treaty will be one
that will institutionalize and then
of course both high income and low
income or
all categories high middle upper middle
low income should listen to a
multi-lateral organization like
who we have been
consistent on this as as you know
although the virus was new and there
could be some things we didn't know
we started by saying we don't know this
but this is what we think you should do
and then we started to learn together
and
we know better now and going forward i
think
that uniform action will be very very
important
yeah no thank you um and so there's
another question from the audience
um about um the the fact that
global health funding has been reactive
rather than sustained uh and sustainable
so and and you very nicely sort of
talked about
learning from crises uh to to move
forward
so how do we ensure going forward that
governments and donors
are held accountable to long-term
impactful
funding for health equity
yeah thank you so much i mean if we're
going to
address that problem that problem is
very visible as you said
uh we have to get outside out of this
probably
out of this panic and neglect cycle
so we always move in a vicious uh cycle
you know panic connect like panic
neglect okay we there is a an epidemic
or outbreak we panic we react
we finance and then as soon as that's
taken care
of then we neglect and and and so on
so we have to uh recognize
health threats as a constant threat
and the same thing can happen anytime so
the world should be prepared
anytime at all times
treat it like for instance a security
problem
countries you know the budgets they have
for their defense or security
it's big and it's sustainable
and i think they have seen how
health actually impacts even
more than a terrorist because they
prepare that because maybe
because they have a threat from their
neighbors or beyond
they prepare because of uh fear of
terrorism but
the virus i think has shown that it has
more impact than what we fear
it has impacted our economy
it has impacted as politically socially
you name it and
the whole world has been taken actually
a hostage
i have never seen since the second world
war if there is
anything that has really frozen the
whole world even second world war
some parts were okay um
so it affected everything
and it has shown that health is
central so
if we cannot finance it sustainably
then i think there is something wrong
with us
we're not listening i think it's
it's it's enough to listen now more than
enough
we were affected the hard way
so we we have we i think we have
listened and that's what i
i believe and there should be a
significant
investment and for sustainability of
funding
where i will start is if we realize that
health is central
and we don't want anything like this to
happen
then the simple answer is we have to
believe in universal health coverage
we should stop commercializing health
health is not a commodity for sale
health should be taken as a human
rights issue
like a foundation
and one ask i have is each and
every country to put it in its
constitution
as a fundamental human rights issue
and commit to health for all and do
whatever
even the poorest on earth whatever
to keep its people healthy
to strengthen its its system
you know um what uk did
because i just want i want i don't want
any country to
have any excuses the uk decided on
nhs immediately after the second world
war
lord beveridge when its economy was in
tatters
it decided to have health for all that's
nhs
so no country can have any excuse
so if we want this not to happen again
i don't see it as financing only and
meaning finance it
then i think that level of commitment
will be very important
healthy central health for all we should
move toward the cells for all
and take it even recognize it in our
constitution many countries have done
that
and all countries should do that and
they shouldn't
commercialize hell when i say this by
the way i have to be clear
i'm not saying private sector should not
be involved and everything should be
public
what i am saying is government should
take responsibility and the services can
be provided through
government public or private sector or
or or what do you call it hybrid
or or one of them it doesn't matter it's
up to the country to choose
but i think the government's spending i
mean
contribution is very very important and
government should take responsibility
to make to make this uh happen
so that's how we can address the
sustainable sustainability of financing
then globally if we do this locally at
national level
then sustaining global efforts will not
be a problem
and for that the recommendations we have
is
global financing let's not try to
have new institutions for global
financing
even for local by the way we can use
imf we can use the world bank we can use
the original binds
of course they should develop some
some flexible processes
very agile processes
but and then commitment to pandemic
preparedness and response
but the existing institutions can do it
thank you sorry i took long on this one
because it's very important
no i agree and it's nuanced so as we
reach uh sort of the the last part of
our conversation
so i want to highlight another question
from from the audience
um as you know that in pandemics and
large public health emergencies
the evidence base is changing so the
question is
is there a way is there a creative way
for global universities to be more
directly helpful to the who
when its needs are acute for
evidence-based reviews and rapid
responses
you know the the collaborating center
model is very much there but as you know
that it takes time
and often new players are needed and
agility is needed in public health
emergencies
so is there you know for example the
questionnaire suggests uh you know
is there a value of a master contract uh
that where
that doesn't involve a lot of money or
perhaps even no money
but there is a framework for rapid
synthesis
of evidence so the intellectual capacity
that is out there
can be fully marshaled um so so we'd
love to hear your thoughts on that
especially as you know one of the agenda
you have
uh within who is the who academy so so
this capacity building this
focus on evidence um is i think in line
with this kind of a question and a
potential proposal
thank you i think you read my mind i was
going to say
oh we have collaborating centers but you
pre-enter by saying i know about
collaborating centers so
this is by the way um we we believe in
networks
we have several networks there some of
them inversible
some of them other institutional based
uh but from the way you say the master
contract
it doesn't mean it involves money of
universities
i think network of those would be very
important
um why not you develop this as a concept
uh what i like about yale is the grand
strategy that's where you
process and bring new ideas so
i i see this as a new idea
just purely universities and we don't go
into that
process of collaborating centers but a
different way of partnership
with universities both in the south and
north
everywhere all over the world low income
high income
middle income and if you can develop a
concept with your students and we would
be happy to have a follow-up discussion
on this but i i think this made it
evolve as a good a good uh
way of uh partnership with who
thank you so much for that wonderful so
so the last question and then we have
the who academy
but the partnership with universities
may not be just for
training it could be other
other things that's why it could be more
than
training of course the who economy
starts with training but for the future
it will have a research arm
so it could that could be the center by
the way
to coordinate all the opportunities
that we can have globally by the way the
wh academy is also
new it's an outcome of the
transformation
and it it can also take part in here but
that's a very
good idea would be happy if you can
develop it further and
have a follow-up meeting so
one last question uh before we wrap up
is
that as we move beyond the pandemic and
you have vociferously advocated from the
beginning
even before you took charge of who about
the
universal healthcare agenda how do we
so the pandemic will subside one way or
another
we will have to be ready for the next
one how do we
re-engage or even engage with
more vigor in the
universal health care agenda in the next
few years
yeah um i think this is very very
important
um we we're already
saying to the international community
what i just said earlier and now because
of this fundament
we know how central health is
and that investing in universal health
coverage is
is the the answer
and the pandemic itself has
already uh what do you call it
um strengthened the
case for health for all or or uhc
uh so we have already started started
engaging
but we will continue to even do it more
but the messages are exactly what i told
you earlier what i said earlier
meaning if you ask me one one thing
very concrete thing that countries can
do
if they can put it their commitment
could be put
in their constitution uhc or
um health for all
so we have a specific ask now to to to
make
and to ask countries when we engage when
we continue to engage
that they should put it in their
constitution because that's the
that's actually uh
how you would know um
how committed a country is when when
they put it in their in their
constitution
so it's it makes it it made it easier
for us now
uh to explain why health is central
uh it's very tragic all that happened
more than 3.2 million people have died
already
because of this pandemic but it has
shown us beyond any doubt
the centrality of of health so there is
already good opportunity to push
the agenda and look forward to working
with you
to push the health for all or the
universal health coverage agenda
thank you very much and as we wrap up
this conversation
i want to uh thank you dr ted rose for
being a passionate
uh advocate for universal healthcare and
uh
very specifically health equity uh for
well before this pandemic and i know
based on that track record that you will
continue to be
a an advocate for global health equity
and and thank you for working with the
fierce urgency of now to paraphrase to
borrow
a phrase from martin luther king
jr that uh you know which was required
in this pandemic
and i think wh shows uh response the
global response
um has shown us the indispensable nature
of institutions like who
and that these institutions matter it
matter for
uh from um you know from kansas to
kathmandu
because we all use one or another
function that
who fulfills the the convening function
or we or the technical guidance function
benefits us all and it is in our
interest to make sure
that these institutions and specifically
who is
healthy and is uh it continues to move
forward so thank you very much for
taking the time
um we really appreciate you being here
today thank you thank you so much
zad and i would appreciate it if you can
also pass my greetings to john goddess
huh
i will absolutely i hope you will find
ways to
fight i will you you can catch him yeah
so thank you thank you so much bye